hi David did you did you uh like did you
want to do this for the network where
you said you didn't want to deal with
like Netflix or any of those guys for
this no I they just you know made a hard
press and they were first of all I like
their platform and what they do it's
kind of interesting I've never done that
before and and they just you know
courted me as it were a shadow pettish
winsome out on a I don't know log
looking you know with some way out of
those yeah the water the river yeah
and they came along and and scooped me
up that's so romantic
a strong arms I was gonna say a girl in
a bus station in New York yeah I feel
like that's all anybody wants out of
their comedy special is right to feel
like that to feel like a little girl
yeah in a boat so it's only online yeah
and it's also in theaters this motive
yeah oh this really okay yeah yeah did
you go to a theater to watch it no I
can't do maybe yeah would you know well
I'm actually considering I don't know
how they're gonna do but I'm gonna
hopefully pop into one of them on
Wednesday that I can get to I haven't
gotten any numbers for it but I have
gotten word from my sources that Marvel
is concerned because they they cornered
that tiny little you know that that one
theater that's got nine seats in it yeah
it's the screens roughly the size of a
TV right right yeah right very where is
it gonna be seen in theaters like in the
UIL a New York Detroit Boston Philly
Riverside California for some reason and
I'm forgetting the other places but yeah
now they're putting it in the theater is
that because they can I want to just
make money off her is that part of
marketing it well look it's taking money
yeah but I don't know I don't know how
that works I don't know that and they've
done this before
and I you know when I was considering it
because I have a good relationship with
Netflix I've done a bunch of stuff from
my last special was on there but I talk
to a bunch of comics who are bigger than
me you know who've gone with comedy
dynamics and and they you know explain
the pros and cons and they were all
happy with it so
oh it's comedy done I like who's doing
this yeah yeah oh is that bird company
it's a well is that bill Burson company
or know what Spillman's company on
there's comedy oh okay okay that's why I
thought what do you have something on
comedy dynamics no okay I don't think so
no I hate my check major money but this
is the first time you've had a special
that would go to movie theaters correct
oh yeah yeah yeah cuz I mean that's what
that's the first thing I thought when I
heard it was like to go and sit in a
movie theater cuz I wouldn't I never
liked to watch any or listen to anything
that I do one else knows either that's
that's the issue but I feel like if it
was in a movie theatre just even if I
had to leave after two minutes just to
experience what that is like I would
have to see well it's just bigger yeah
but I would have to see how much bigger
but you also people sitting in theater
seats and the whole thing I know it'd be
it's pretty cool I'm I like the idea of
it it's yeah it's a little overwhelming
but the laughs come and that's what
would scare me is like waiting for the
laughs like I went to the premiere oh
yeah comedy that did did not get the
laughs anticipated and it's a
humiliating when you watch especially
major actors who have know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna go to one of these
theaters and bring in like a tiny little
but powerful speaker that's maybe the
scariest part though is like if a joke
doesn't land in the live audience
watching it will be so difficult well
but yeah this this it's all good I mean
not to you know be conceited about it
but I mean it was a strong session
strong so it's it's it plays on the
screen and through the speakers they'll
be laughs but you know whether the
people they're just sort of looking at
it but it's you know New York audiences
can have a tendency to when they see
something funny or hear something funny
do their reaction is more like this like
mmm like an acknowledgment you have the
humorous value exactly I understand
reference right like well you could have
done that through the sounds of hahaha
yes yeah that's kind of what we human
CBS was on we have it on the prep sheet
on CBS you talked about being abandoned
and that kind of freaks you out the idea
that you might do it
the idea that I might talk about it on
TV the idea that you're like we're
concerned that you would do yeah yeah
well the I was watching that I love that
you told him you're like cuz once you
get into it you're like I don't know if
I want to talk about this on CBS this
morning actually started to get a little
emotional because I haven't really
addressed it and it completely came up
organically I mean that's like a
45-minute hour-long interview that they
chopped up in the six minutes no but um
but once we got into it it was it was
odd and I was I was like keeping my [ __ ]
together because I didn't I haven't
really talked about but it was the idea
because a lot of what anchors the new
special is that I have a kid never had a
kid before so that that was kind of a
thrust of the interview too and then and
just sort of organically started talking
about how and this is true like I always
I always wanted kids but I was reluctant
cuz I wondered still do whether I have
that thing in me that my dad had which
allowed him just to walk away from three
kids and a wife and just to leave and go
ma'am not this isn't my thing
how old is your kid now um how old were
you in that I was 10 some reason that's
the CBS thing they said I was a teenager
but I was 10 and my five two younger
sisters and they would have been eight
and five and my daughter now is a little
over 2 so I - I mean could you even
conceive of doing that no not at all
Ryan I well no that's not true in my
darkest recesses I can conceive of it I
can imagine it I've got a pretty good
imagination I didn't imagine that but it
was about the justification for it you
know the right because what he didn't
just leave he just left and didn't stay
in touch and went far away and left us
in severe debt he was really
irresponsible and
we were moving around constantly he'd
get fired a lot and he it was that it's
one of the things that bothers me so
much about Trump as my dad has those
qualities he's very narcissistic nothing
is ever his fault you know he will make
this a pathological liar putting himself
in a greater light you know when you can
you know objectively look back and go
well that's not true you you're
completely that fault here yeah and and
just the idea to talk to him sense yeah
I guess I don't talk to him since I was
19 that was the there were there were
you know cuz I still had I was 10 and I
still had that kind of dad worship
things and I and my mom was never the
kind of person go you're your dad's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ]
you know and she had every reason to but
she didn't do that and so until I was
like 16 17 when it started to kind of
the the veil was pulled slowly I mean I
thought my dad was [ __ ] balls man and
he was living this cool life and he was
and he was also personality was very
different from my mom my mom was very
bookish and antisocial and awkward and
intellectual my dad was the complete
opposite wasn't very was street smart
but not smart smart and was very affable
and outgoing and and gregarious and and
life of the party kind of guy complete
opposites and and I don't know why I
brought that up but uh you I just liked
him I still liked him he was a cool guy
and I actually went to live with him in
Arizona I went when I was 13 13 so I'm
like that 14 maybe and we were and and
he had no money and no job and we were
eating vending machine snacks cuz he
knew a guy who filled vending machines
so he had Boston baked beans I'll never
forget this it was about four or five
month period in Scottsdale Arizona
initially we were staying in a
guest rooms somebody's house and the mom
and the daughters liked us and the
stepdad got it immediately I think I
have only got this in retrospect my
stepdad the their stepdad was like knew
my dad was scamming him and just full of
[ __ ] and and then we were kind of kicked
out of there we went to the obvious a
long story it's a long I'll say for the
memoir 19 did you you didn't do you want
to talk to man or is he does he don't no
not at all no he's alive he's here in
New York I have not seen him since I was
19 and and I talked I I can tell you the
exact thing that made me go it's just
too long to bring up here was like
that's it that's enough and I told my
sister was on the phone with him he had
called and I said tell him I don't want
to speak them anymore
and he said I'll never forget this and I
quote that's all right the only time he
ever talks to me is when he wants money
which is like the most insane yeah why
first of all he had no money he never
gave us any money took my bar mitzvah
money Wow yeah he I mean it's crazy the
way he but that does it yeah like you're
the villain yeah because all you have to
do it all I the only time oh it's it's
just the literally the exact opposite of
the truth Wow and and when he said that
just sealed it you're like you know what
there's never gonna be a moment where he
gets it he's not gonna see it this way
he's just not gonna ever never but but I
mean the demonstrative demonstrable eve
all the things he did the shitty put my
mom through and now that I'm a parent
like I I kind of really in a bad way
took for granted what my mom had to do
to raise us but literally not not just
no money but in debt and this is back in
the 70s when you know there was there
were no ATMs there are no check cashing
places I mean she had no money and we
were in debt and we were in this shitty
apartment in Roswell Georgia and
and my dad's gone off to Arizona and and
he's also sleeping around you know
constantly and we found that [ __ ] out
later but you know my mom had to like
get a like I should like a Chevron
credit card and pay that off to get a
Sears card
hey that off like oh and and and just
have this bad job and she's raising
three kids who don't fully get the why
can't I have that and we're eating you
know like powdered milk and government
cheese and stuff like that it was it was
just but it seemed like she did an
amazing job of not putting her stress on
you the fact that you guys didn't even
realize no I mean I I just I can't
imagine one kid and money and help yeah
and a wife who's there eh I mean to have
three kids no help and no money and I
mean it's it was it was rough has he
reached out to you at all since you
became successful um he has made a
couple of thinly veiled attempts through
my sister than one sister was sort of
she's kind of over it too but he was the
last she was the last person he
completely [ __ ] over so there was
still a bit of a relationship right he
made some sort of efforts early early on
but that's it but he still kind of see
you think he's probably the same guy
like so you know some people just don't
I know people who've seen them and when
I have relatives to and yeah yeah I am
it's not I want to go into the whole
thing but do you see any of like the
when you're with your kid whether you
have to you're disciplining them or
whatever do you see any of the little
traits in you that were in him for those
first ten years not necessary
I'm a bad guy and I'm gonna leave but
just like the little like the way I'm
gonna tell you to do something or the
way I scold you or there's such a
distant memory I might I do use in
English accent British yeah and but not
I mean I
I do beat the [ __ ] out of her
[Laughter]
I don't but I have but I'm not aware of
it right maybe I blocked it all out I
don't know yeah yeah that seems that way
do you like being a father though do you
like me I love it
yeah does it feel like you've does it
stabilize life for you um it definitely
I don't know about stabilizing it well
yeah sure I mean I I'm I have to be more
responsible now and so that part of me
has changed but I think that would have
changed anyway with you know just aging
but yeah I mean it that's part of what
the special is about you know slightly
there's it that that that kind of idea
that one's through it that the stuff
that I'm talking about now has a
different kind there's an urgency to it
that it was easy and other specials to
take the subject matter go well this is
kind of [ __ ] up now there's a there's
a whole thing to it as a comic to
talking about something I'm a dad or is
it hard as a comment giving [ __ ] I swore
I would never talk about this but now
that it's actually a part I doing my god
I thought about that that's in the
beginning of the I'm like look I and you
know and and Laurie I'll finish my
thought that I I'm not gonna do an hour
of dad jokes I'm very hyper aware that
it would you know first of all make me
such a hypocrite you know based on
material I've done in the past and and
it's boring
nobody wants an hour of
fill-in-the-blank jokes I never that
whole concept of going and structuring
shows like an evening of gay comedy yes
ladies of laughter I thank you I I
absolutely know I mean they're all
probably really wonderful comics but
yeah I don't want to be an hour of
fill-in-the-blank comedy like that I'm
going to the dad jokes show I don't know
it's just dad dad's over 40 who have
been abandoned yes so yeah I address
that kind of and the set was sort was
developed in you know was all done here
in Brooklyn or new
and and I've never done a set from
scratch before ever and I just sort of
built it up over months and towards the
end I would ask the audience you know
stick around Q&A except I'd be asking
the questions and I'd say like you know
do is does this feel like too many dad
jokes not enough should I switch up
where should I do it and and the
audience was extremely helpful and and
and I saw I got through there you know
different audiences like kind of what I
think is that so the perfect amount
that's really interesting that you
wouldn't just listen to reactions you'd
actually go the extra step and go let me
talk to these people yeah their actual
feedback well there's I mean again this
sounds obsequious and corny but I mean I
have great fans and and I was as I said
months and months and months putting
these shows together in Brooklyn and
they were extremely helpful they came
the audience came up with the title for
the show do you ever say it was there
any advice they gave you like a [ __ ] how
do I lose that one like was there
anything they told you that was the
truth that you do like yeah it was kind
of a hard one to take I there were
probably a couple things where they were
bits that I was able to justify you know
of one person or a handful of people at
different shows not liking a bit gun
will [ __ ] them the other cattle liked it
and you know I know it's like offensive
or whatever but I'm gonna do it anyway
so but you'd keep it in if you were like
I feel I feel stronger every single
comic has at least one or two jokes that
are I know it doesn't you're always
doing that well 45 minutes
you're almost prideful of the silence
cuz you're like yep yeah it was mine and
you're convinced it's gonna work someday
like I know it's good I know and then
you it is gonna work someday you're
gonna be at a Holiday Inn and it's gonna
work and it go like see that's right and
then that's literally bought eight more
years of that same joke bombing do you
have any fans that you respect more than
others in the sense that like they
recognize you from one thing or the
other meaning if somebody comes up to
you and goes hey man from the chipmunks
sure
Hey nice to meet you versus like is
there is there a pinnacle of like yep
you're my people because you like me in
yes definitely there are you know some
of the more obscure kind of colty stuff
if people like it and in sometimes
they'll reference something that I'm
like oh wow you've that is you really
pick something out there that is cool
like what's the number one thing for you
that you've been in the that would get
that reaction of Alvin and the Chipmunks
[Laughter]
it it really depends I mean geez I mean
there have been a couple of little like
indie films I've done it's probably Todd
Margaret was a big one you know people
know that one and know of it not you
know and just and have seen the whole
thing and then like early or stand-up or
whatever but definitely more you know
list to divide it in half there's like
you know chipmunks and scary movie and
Arrested Development not that arrests
bill development isn't great but you
know every la fenix yeah and then some
of the you know works gear stuff movie
called it's a disaster that was really
fun to do that I really like what I did
in it you know if somebody listens to
this and tries to reference one of those
movies and then when you start talking
about it you realize you've never you
know I've never seen oh no the Chipmunks
you said wasn't a pleasant working what
kind of clashes do you have with the
directors like you know like there was
only the third one the third one the
first two were fine and the third one
had nothing to do with the director and
they were the people when we were making
it were all very sympathetic to what
they were doing and now we're totally
cool it was it that was fine that was
great they were quite helpful actually
but the there were just a handful of
producers home women Karen Rosenfelt
and then this other woman camera name
but just inexplicably
shitty and and like took measures to
make my life miserable because I there's
such a long backstory but I was
already I was in London getting ready I
was in pre-production on the second
series of Todd Margaret and you know I
produced that as well as everything else
so I've got you know 70 people you know
who's have a job you know or looking to
me and you know relying on me for a job
and and we've been asking them because
I'm contrived I was contractually
obligated to do it there's no way to get
out of it and we had been asking him for
months am I gonna be a part of it cuz of
coz of Todd Margaret and they were like
we don't know kind of go back and forth
never gave us a real answer and then I
remember very well I was at this
department store with my wife and I get
a call you know there's an 8 hour
difference between London and and I
answer the call you can see it's my
manager I answer the call and they're
like I David I have and then this litany
of names you know agents and and lawyers
and all that stuff on line for you I was
like and that's only thank you that's
only good news or bad news it's never
anything in between it's only like
something really good or something
really never casual it's never casual
it's there's 15 people they just wanted
to say hey yeah and they said ok he's
sitting down so I know it's bad and then
they're like so Alvin and the Chipmunks
is gonna happen and like okay well what
does that mean and it's happened they
want you there in two weeks and I you
know like my heart started racing like
where you get kind of angry and you get
a little flush and like what and they
they had anticipated all that stuff and
they they even said they're at that
point they're being really shitty so it
turns out but you're contractually
obligated contractually obligated and I
have all these people I mean I'm
probably under estimating it that well I
mean it's probably when you're talking
about actors and and department heads
and people in the department you talk
about a hundred plus right all the way
all the you know trans
bow and craft sir I mean everybody so it
was it was crazy it was just crazy and
then I'm like I can't even physically
get they wanted me to go to Hawaii for
rehearsals it was just the nut it was
and and when we pushed back and going
can I get three extra days can I go to I
have to go to New York to get clothing
you know I'm living in London now and
they're like no you have to be there for
her I'll be just rehearsals yeah it's
the third one is it actually are you
physically in the costume there or is it
only vo uh no I'm in I was playing a you
know live character but I was also
another big source of contention was
that I just was to learn that Jim Norton
is not an alpha helix fan surprise I'm
disappointed learn you Wharton won the
chipmunk hey oh yeah then we'll do we'll
fix him post so you so that was the that
was really the rigmarole of the whole
thing and that never that energy never
kind of stopped throughout the filming
no they were they were so there was a
whole scene two weeks or I think it was
12 days on a cruise ship and initially
the characters only literally only as
scripted only in a pelican costume or
whatever the custom is I'm like well
clearly I don't have to go on the cruise
ship I can fly back to London and you
know somebody else could unit Halligan
gosh yeah yeah
and then the woman's like I remember
calling her like begging pleading Karen
please like now you're in the cover set
I like look and she said you have a
distinctive walk but also it was fate it
was it was bad logic because before I
was
so they eventually have the guy take the
the character take the head off
but as scripted what they're planning
was you just see the pelican guy and
he's chasing the Dave character or
whatever I was trying to get the
Chipmunks or whatever and they're like
no you have a distinctive walk but as
scripted they you're not supposed to
know it's my character until later so
the audience is not right even the
audience is like well now you're just
being shitty okay and you know and the
other thing is when they said yeah
you're in it I mean I'm all over it
I'm throughout that script and like well
you guys could have told us months ago
you don't just radically come up insert
a character and then 90 pages of what
you do with Todd Todd Margaret we had a
postponement oh you just kind of put it
on hold yeah
oh I mean everybody understood but it
was really and we lost some people we
lost some people they've now got other
projects and they were gonna do after
Todd Margaret or whatever it is these
things that's the other thing I'm a
producer and I know how monumentally
unnecessarily shitty that was you don't
have to do that every single step of the
way you don't have to do that had you
ever worked with her before yon the
first two and was she okay the first
times yeah it was Howard trip thing
where all of a sudden you had this other
thing so they wanted to be like hey
let's Humble David a little bit
interesting I do I don't think it was
that but I do think there's a thing in
Hollywood especially amongst agents and
producers agents lawyers producers
there's a thing and that the talent has
nothing to do with it they're just on
the periphery of this idea of you know
that kind of mentality that some people
have of they love a good fight they you
see it in politics a lot where they're
chummy
after this acrimonious battle right and
people are are having lunch the next day
together and there's that thing of like
winning I want to win doesn't matter it
doesn't matter what what the the you
know the [ __ ] that I've laid the path
that I've left here them the what
matters is that I want it didn't matter
what we're winning doesn't matter when
the fight
yeah and you get that sense that it was
about my guys versus their guys and it
didn't matter about me it didn't matter
about the project they don't give a [ __ ]
about album they do it's a money mate
it's a bank right you know they don't
care about the you know my new shava she
didn't want to lose the point see that I
truly believe it was about winning Wow
and was any and you're sitting here
going like how do we just make this so
that everything works yeah for everybody
with differences and it's what I've
always done yeah what what most people
do yeah but I truly don't think it was
and also you know I it's not like I
didn't do a good job in those first two
like they would have any any reason to
be upset with me I go in I was
professional I was early or you know I
was on time every day and I add lip
stuff and I you know collaborated with
other people on set and and I did what I
did it at bet any project you know it's
just it was crazy and really just be
helpful and yeah again I produced a ton
of stuff and if somebody has an issue
you go back and you genuinely tried it
you look at the board how can we make
this work for everybody so everybody
kind of goes in happy you talk to a do
do is talk about you you weren't in
support of your wife was a Hillary
supporter so you guys do butt heads a
little bit hearing that like as a
married couple or butt heads a little
bit
can you imagine I'm fascinated with
Kellyanne Conway I'm George comic how
the fight is that marriage work man I
don't know I mean hate [ __ ] I can't
imagine like what do they say when they
get home like she's with Trump and then
Trump is finally like I got a bad mouth
here husband and the husband that's just
attacking the guys you were how they
imagine if your wife's boss you know
your wife's boss is insulting you right
now imagine if your wife's boss is the
president inez Trump and he's doing it
publicly it's not just that you have to
add the element that he knows and you
know she knows too that she is lying he
knows that when they have a conversation
you can you can [ __ ] America you
can't [ __ ] me well I know you're
lying I know what the situation is that
adds a whole other element to it where I
go I don't know how they do this I don't
know right like how you how do you even
respect somebody who's like that's my
job yeah how do you communicate well at
home though are they
like is it different at home is it that
same thing like like what's his name
James Carville and his wife you know the
Republican strategist Democratic yeah is
it is it that or is this this seems like
it goes a little bit different yeah
those were two different philosophies I
get that there have been thinking how
many relationships and marriages there
been where one's conservative one's
liberal and you know I mean it's like
you know the basis for TV shows and [ __ ]
yeah decades but the idea that you would
be the mouthpiece you would lie for
somebody who we all know is lying
especially George Connelly he knows his
wife that's the part where like you
can't you can't lie to me you know right
like how does it how does the
conversation go from that point forward
yeah I don't know I don't know how they
do it I do not hate him for attacking
her boss like could you just shut the
[ __ ] up you're [ __ ] with me I had he
not hate her for working for somebody
and being so vocal for something that he
obviously disagrees with so much yeah
it's so I I would love to know what
they're like either either gonna get
divorced or this is just completely fine
with both of them I don't see how it's
it's a it's really curious like
regardless of who you work for can you
imagine your spouse verbally
bad-mouthing you know let you know your
boss and it just yeah how [ __ ]
frustrating that would be or are you
imagine your spouse working for a guy
you hate yeah and you know she hates not
that I know if any conflict still exists
anymore or not but have you thought
about trying to get the entire Arrested
Development cast into a room together
and just working them all out just say
give us however many weeks it takes so
we can squeeze out another season unless
that's not an issue I don't I don't
think it would be an issue I don't think
III really don't I mean there are
obviously two people that had a blow-up
and it wasn't handled well but I do
believe those two people are you know
smart and and not even deep down just
even on the surface love each other and
respect each other and can work that out
as two people can and and you know were
we were very much like a family we were
together we 15 years we go back yeah
from when we started and anything can be
worked out with just discussion that uh
nob viously and unfortunately played out
in the public forum and then had a life
of its own because that's what people
that's how people one of the ways people
make money to do these days is you go
and you talk about something that you
weren't a part of and you talk about in
you you opine and you've opine about a
person's comment and then you've still
you know and you start even filling in
stuff that wasn't even you weren't privy
to you just presuppose a bunch of things
and that that's how people make money
and you get cliques and stuff and adding
motives that didn't exist yet yeah yep
and and the two individuals I'm I'm a
100 percent convinced could work it out
all of us could work it out absolutely
we're friends we know each other we love
each other we have respect for each
other it just like in a family family
blow up arguments happen people blow up
and yeah when things that are private or
played out in public and there's a whole
different a whole nother dynamic to it
yeah everybody else feels like they have
an investment in it and they have a say
and that this is now a bigger thing than
it would have been if it was just a
private yeah argument you know what
unfortunately there was that initial
argument then there was a thing that
that not only it didn't look good for a
reason because it wasn't good and when
we didn't handle it well but there's
another step that can obviously sure
several steps can happen after that you
get together after that and and we also
that was literally the end of a long
press thing and we're all leaving so
that that we didn't even get that chance
you know alright he was emailing and
talking privately but not the rest of it
played out in the public forum and
that's the number good but yeah but
that's I don't think that's the issue
that's not really the issue are there is
there other issues yeah I just don't
think we would want the actors would
want to work that way again it was not a
good working situation and it's one
things that I think in no small part in
light
lent itself to what happened on set one
more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM attic